okay everybody some big Star Wars news
dropped this week alongside the solo
premiere the upcoming Boba Fett movie
will be written and directed by James
Mangold best known for directing Logan
last year and the Wolverine in 2013 now
Fantastic Four reboot director Josh
Trank was originally attached to direct
the movie but he left the project in
2014 leaving Vince the wunderkind no he
walked away from that to Fantastic Four
and he he is working on some Al Capone
movie that's coming out but anyway we
were all wondering if Boba Fett was even
gonna happen as a movie the bounty
hunter has always been a fan favorite
director from the original trilogy even
Utley famous only had like four or five
lines a dialogue and the died of Barry
unceremonious death falling in the
Sarlacc pit on Tatooine but people loved
this guy and we saw a young version of
boba that of course in the prequels the
clone son figure to Jango Fett on Kamino
and attack of the clones we last saw him
on Geonosis yeah it's all there George
Isaac eat all of it
but he was on Geonosis holding Jango
severed head and the Mandalorian star
wore a helmet that he'd probably inherit
he's really pissed off at now but James
Mangold has taken over this guy's it's
very exciting we're still waiting for
confirmation on the story of what
exactly's Boba Fett movie will be you'll
probably show it's time as a bounty
hunter piloting slave 1 between the
events of clones and the first
appearance of Empire Strikes Back but
choosing James Mangold as a director of
this project suggests that Lucas pose
looking for a tone that's grounded and
gritty violent maybe a little Western II
what elements do you guys think from
mengel's work and Logan do you think
could really work the best going into a
Boba Fett movie honestly he probably
would have done an okay job may be equal
to or better with a han Solo movie - if
you wanted because there was a Western
you feel to this - just solo i if lean
into the Western because I feel like
Star Wars fans are still gonna be kind
of disappointed with this movie like no
matter what like I don't feel like
that's what's gonna happen looks at me
when you said that I just like this view
I can see this conversation happening in
the future where it's just like it's not
gonna it's not be perfect but I think he
can have some fun with if he were to
lean more into his Western roots he did
it 3:10 to Yuma and Wolverine and Logan
and there
loves him for those movies so aim for
that and I think we'll be happy I just
don't see fans being happy with this
movie I could just see it because a bear
time basically I can't I story was
totally open that's a good slate that's
kind of like what Sam has said
previously was people are like do we
need it and it's like you don't know no
no until they somebody writes a story
that might be the best story ever told
yeah it's Casablanca with Boba Fett or
something but yeah I think it could be
great and something from Logan that I
think he could take I don't know if you
guys felt this vibe at least the
character of Logan did he was painted as
if he's an antihero as if he's been the
villain previously because that's where
he's at mentally by the time that
movie's taking place and so he feels
like look I'm a bad guy even though we
all like cheer for Wolverine he feels
like he's a bad guy and the fact that
then the rest of movie it's like whoa
even if he feels like a bad guy how do
you get him to come out and do something
for at least one good reason how do you
get him to save his soul this guy's a
bounty hunter and I think that he could
go through a similar thing of like look
I'm a bounty hunter for a very specific
reason and that's a path I've chosen but
is there something that I'm not
necessarily saying you have to do that
thing where it's like but there's kids
to save you know on the edge of the
cliff whatever like it doesn't have to
be that but there is a way to make it so
that Boba Fett can be someone that we
want to root for and and emotionally
connect with even though we only know
how much I belong yeah it'd be fun to
see like so James Mangold I am very
excited to see that like the way he can
humanize a character who's kind of
become a bit of a joke to some people
like you think when he took over
Wolverine after x-men origins that was
like the lowest possible point and the
Wolverine adaptations on film and then
when he took over in the Wolverine and
with Logan it's like he brought a new
humanity the character that we're all
dying to see I recently watched a movie
that was a Western called Wind River
it's with Jeremy Renner's and he plays a
hunter who ends up like doing his way of
solving a crime on a reservation a
woman's raped and she dies and he has to
work with an FBI agent to uncover what
really happened and it was this great
Western and I realize not really Jeremy
Renner's character's story as much in it
he's just his character doesn't really
change there's like a detective story
it's a detective story every line
way he starts the movie is the way he
ends it and I don't know if I really
want to see Boba Fett transition I'd
rather just see him as this badass
character who just like picks up
whatever this case is if it's like
chasing down someone who got away with
some crime and he has to go find them
and like Clint Eastwood Unforgiven style
where and he just becomes who he is
meant to be kind of a task killer
so more thing to yeah I do like this the
story where it can go so in Clone Wars
Boba Fett is raised by bounty hunters
and you have really cool characters like
bosque who basically looks like a
dinosaur and a tree trunk got combined
but like a lot of fun because in the
video games you played it as a boss
character and then there's like a sniper
I forget her name but she's awesome
sexy girl but having like this full-on
unit I could see it being like a suicide
esque squad kind of thing where they're
all working together probably on some of
the bounties and their probably
splitting it but they're also trying to
deceive each other and then you know
it's like that element which i think
would be a lot of fun the one thing that
I really really hope doesn't happen
which did happen in episode 7 what was
that one course weakens thank you which
is when you introduced to the character
Kyler the average person has only ever
seen him with his helmet on and when
Kyla was first introduced you only saw
him with his helmet on and then he took
his helmet off and everyone laughed
everyone laughed in the two times I
watched it in cinema everyone laughed
and I'm scared that when you finally do
reveal who this Boba Fett character
could be that as soon as you have a face
that's kind of like revealed when it's
the helmet that's so iconic that it lets
people down we have an indication of
what he probably looks like maybe but
yeah there's something College
interesting if you don't show his face
too if you if it like maybe you saw Adam
driver like what if he took it off and
you only see it and back behind so you
only see like he's got like brown hair
that's all you know but like that's a
really interesting kind of like yeah it
if it were more in the Western vein of
it he is like a legend he is like the
Ghost Rider who comes through a town and
he leaves again like you've ever there's
something there that you can kind of
flare I like all that I don't agree with
the idea of not seeing his face I think
it's like a fundamental inherent thing
that we have to connect with
eyes and like it's why I think it was
such a breakthrough that spider-man's
eyes could change or also Deadpool's
eyes are pretty animated - it's like
otherwise you are just looking at a
machine unless you pair him with someone
who has so much humanity their character
and he that character becomes a foil for
his behavior - so we were able to
identify with Boba Fett's during heaven
James about boba fett which I think
could be worth exploring is the actual
planet of Mandalore like we haven't
really gone to Mandalore before and
that's where obi-wan is really heavily
involved and it could be a really good
tie in together I actually wouldn't mind
seeing well those people are fascinating
- like they consistently are some of the
best characters and when you were
touching on the idea of like his crew
like it'd be fun to see like assassins
as a crew we kind of keep thinking that
we're gonna get the the Dirty Dozen and
they're really like tough criminals and
stuff and we kind of keep not kidding
you know yeah movies now yeah well let
us know what you're hoping to see from
this Boba Fett movie and what you liked
most about Logan that you hoped could
translate over into this Star Wars
universe now that James Mangold is doing
this but as a reminder subscribe to new
rock stars for all of our deeper
insights into Star Wars and all the
stuff you love thanks everybody